ronald reagan said it is up to us in our
time to choose and to choose wisely
between the hard but necessary task of
preserving peace and freedom
and then she said this about former
president trump it has become clear
that the efforts donald trump oversaw
and engaged in were even more chilling
and more threatening than we could have
imagined
clear to whom maybe her maybe adam
schiff maybe adam kinzinger but she also
closed out her speech by saying that
she's standing up for truth her truth
doesn't seem to comport with the reality
of the facts of that day though
there were some protesters there outside
the reagan library and someone left this
this iconic liz cheney george bush
match-up
mashup i should say from grand old memes
which has become an iconic symbol of liz
cheney and her father's republican party
you can see what it says there liz
cheney is a rhino the january 6
committee
is a sham is it a sham let's welcome in
somebody to get some assessment on that
host of the reuben report dave rubin
dave great to talk to you
let's bring in our sham expert dave
rubin all right john what do you got for
me
so have you tuned in and watched any of
this committee
no i've barely watched a minute of this
thing because it was a sham from the
beginning very obviously however i did
see all of the clips of that ridiculous
obviously fake uh scripted testimony
that donald trump jumped from the back
of a limo 74 year old slightly
overweight donald trump jumped hair
flowing he grabbed the steering wheel he
grabbed the clavicle of an fbi guy or a
secret service guy commandeered this
thing it's just
complete nonsense you know what's next
he punched gary oldman in the face and
said got off my plane
i mean these people these people are
just completely ridiculous liz cheney i
mean man she is barely going to be a
footnote in history she has done nothing
for her state she has wasted taxpayer
money on this complete clown show uh you
know she's a pet republican there are a
certain amount of republicans there are
too many of them i would say who like to
go on msnbc and be pet by joe
scarborough or whoever the the silly
people over there are on that televised
mental institution and told that they're
good as they accomplish nothing as they
conserve nothing and as they do nothing
for their constituents but i'm pretty
sure that liz cheney is going to get
voted out in just a couple months she
has put aside anything that she used to
stand for as a quote-unquote
conservative or republican just to focus
and completely sell out on this january
6 committee and dave this was my
favorite part of the hearing yesterday
it's when liz cheney and cassidy
hutchinson took a moment to embrace
because you know that's really uh you
know shows us that this is a serious
fact-finding mission a nice hug from the
star witness and the chief prosecutor of
this
committee it's it's so i mean look at
the hug too the way it's so warm and
loving but it's just so ridiculous just
on its face on its face the idea that
this woman sat on this information for
18 months for 18 months she knew that
donald trump grabbed the steering wheel
and the clavicle and he was going to
drive the car into the capital like a
crazy person and she sat on it for 18
months only to recite the story in
perfect diction to a group of
pre-selected democrats and sycophants
and then of course literally what was it
seven minutes later the agents are like
yeah we'll testify it didn't happen it's
such bananas lunacy brought to us by
the progressives and liz cheney in that
former abc news producer and you know if
you call it a clavicle and not a
collarbone people will take you more
seriously because you know you're using
you know medical terminology here all
right let's move on let's move on from
from liz cheney and talk about uh
florida governor ron desantis he's
apparently closing the gap on president
trump and his potential 2024 matchup
desantis also continues to rake in tons
of cash for his re-election campaign for
florida governor let's not forget about
that and he's getting support
from some guy
who i believe you said he would
eventually come out and support ron
desantis not too long ago but here is
joe rogan
i think ron desantis would work as a
good president i think i mean what he's
done for florida has been admirable he
is not perfect he's a human being but um
what he's done is stand up for freedoms
and people think that
so this this was some weird gaslighting
that went on where people equated
freedom and saying the word freedom to
like right wing bigotry and hate is so
strange
first of all i love that point too just
because you like freedom doesn't mean
you're a right-wing bigot
but let's go ahead and give you a chance
to take a victory lap yourself dave you
called this didn't you
i called it sort of too joe rogan's face
a couple years ago i predicted that he
would be moving to texas or at le at the
very least leaving california because of
taxes which he did
and look joe rogan is a guy who this is
a bernie supporter i mean he had bernie
on his show i believe he supported
bernie just a couple of years ago but
he's showing what i think is a natural
evolution of realizing that big
government and especially woke politics
simply do not work high taxes simply
does not work and for any of the people
out there and there are plenty of them
by the way uh who you know felt that
trump was just a bridge too far they
didn't like his attitude or whatever it
might be now i say this is someone who
supported donald trump and i've
interviewed donald trump and i think
he's a good guy and i wish he was
president but there's a certain amount
of people that just couldn't get there
so what rogan is signaling to his
massive audience is hey here's a guy who
is actually getting things done who kept
a state open who is getting critical
race theory out of schools who is
fighting all this gender nonsense who
actually cares about science who is
fighting the mainstream media all of
those things so he's really showing
people hey maybe you couldn't get there
with trump and what he's sort of saying
is hey i myself couldn't get there with
trump but here's a guy who's doing the
work that we wanted trump to do and it
doesn't come with some of that baggage
and john you and i have discussed this
before but this is where i want trump
and desantis i hope we'll just have some
kind of sit down it does not have to be
on newsmax it does not have to be on the
reuben report but have a well done steak
with ketchup and figure this thing out
well done stick with ketchup hello um
yeah that's very true dave
very true i don't know what desantis
likes but um yeah i don't think any
anybody's gonna run against donald trump
if he does decide around i don't know if
they should or shouldn't uh but you know
he might have a clear path uh let's move
on and you know speaking of bigots and
white supremacists we need to talk about
the co-creator of the popular tv show
friends
she's
doing some self-reflection here uh my
marta kaufman says that she's
embarrassed by the lack of diversity on
the show she's now donating four million
dollars to her alma mater brandeis
university which is a bastion of freedom
and free thinking not um but she hopes
to empower a professorship for
african-american studies there also
david schwimmer has come out and he says
he recognizes his white privilege i'm
very aware of my white privileges that a
heterosexual male whose parents were
able to pay for private education i've
always felt a sense of responsibility to
give back and call things out if i see
the abuse of power
so
i mean are these guys putting
it's friends it's a sitcom on tv
dave it's not roots it's not like some
what are we supposed to make of this
uh well first off john i want to be very
clear about one thing which is that i'm
a seinfeld guy not a friends guy okay so
i just want to put that out there i
don't want people watching this going oh
ruben love friends
i like seinfeld that's number one number
two these people are just pathetic
posturing buffoons basically uh there is
nothing friends may not have been the
greatest uh comedic show in in history
at least by my estimation but millions
and millions of people loved it it was
number one on nbc for probably at least
half a decade or something no one has
anything to apologize over you know this
is where seth macfarlane has apologized
for making gay jokes on family guy and
hank azaria has apologized for doing
apoo in the simpsons it's so
embarrassing and pathetic because
they're throwing they're throwing dirt
on their own legacies i may not have
thought friends was the greatest show
ever but millions of other people did
millions of other people including
myself thought that the simpsons in its
peak years was the most most wonderful
show and no one ever became racist
against american indians uh because of
uh because of apu actually you learned
an awful lot about it these people they
suffer from some sort of brain worm that
they think that if they just bow long
enough if david schwimmer just bows long
enough that somehow the woke machine
won't come get him too it's it's an
inner guilt that's almost impossible to
to fully wrap your head around yeah but
if anything sorry sorry kathleen i don't
think four million's enough let's do
eight million cal poly why stop will be
the magic number and schwimmer what are
you doing still acting i mean any role
that you take schwimmer could be taken
by a black trans disabled actress true
or false swimmer come on you're not that
good
trailer david schwimmer i haven't
thought about him in a long time dave
ruin but he uh he's out there talking
about it great to see you as always dave
and we'll check in again with you very
soon
care oh and happy birthday too by the
see
take
way belated dave rubin celebrating a
birthday recently so hot tip i'm
catching up to you man
oh no it's the other way around it's the
other way around
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell